une nette majorité de chiliens à rejeter
le projet de constitution qui leur a été
soumis exceptionnellement le vote est
obligatoire ce qui explique la grande
influence et une participation de 80% 15
millions de chiliens devait approuver ou
rejeter un projet de constitution
rédigée par une convention 255 citoyen
représentant la société civile il
s'agissait de remplacer la vieille
constitution de la dictature pinochet
considéré comme un frein à la justice
sociale en privilégiant une croissance
économique néolibéral profondément
inégalitaire
un texte de 170 pages
388 article qui voulaient en chasser un
nombre impressionnant de droit à la
santé et à l'éducation publique à des
retraites et des logements décents le
droit à l'avortement aussi
le gouvernement de gabriel boric qui a
voté à punta arenas à l'extrême sud du
chili était sur la sellette c'est un
gouvernement qui à mon avis il s'est
rapproché trop delà de la constitution
alors pas mal de votants vont voter non
pour la constitution mais le bon côté
s'ils approuvent ou le rejettent
l'actuel gouvernement trop et trop vite
dans un pays encore très conservateur
quel que soit le résultat avait dit
président boris le processus doit
continuer dans un esprit d'unité estimé
compromettent aux abonnés tony parker
pas reconstruire un congrès il associa
civile comme les chiliens ont clairement
dit en 2020 dans un premier référendum
qu'il voulait une nouvelle constitution
il va falloir recommencer moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est une nouvelle
étape parce que ceux qui sont pour
l'approbation ou le rejet il ils savent
qu'ils doivent le faire c'est-à-dire
leur et j'ai c'est élire une nouvelle
convention
notre constituante un consensus entre
partis politiques le président beaux
riches devra faire preuve d'imagination
et d'habilité jean michel leprince a du
canada montréal